I think a lot of people get advised to
surrender so that they look compliant
right like if you're if you're being
accused of being a criminal Enterprise
that's like trying to overthrow the
government then you want to look like no
no we respect the government and what
they ask us to do uh but I think there
are probably kind of Bolder steps that
could have been taken I am kind of
amused by how much of a a a joke this
already appears like I think Chris
Bertman had a tweet that was like this
Brady Bunch reunion looks crazy and it's
all of the mug shots that have come out
like it's the being able to see this
like wave of people that you're familiar
with in these mug shots does have sort
of a ludicrous effect we're sharing it
you America's mayor for God's sake from
911 to in a tie and a mug shot it's
Jason Miller just posted a photo of
trump boarding Air Force One at
Signature Flight Support a private
Airline terminal it's the private
terminal and there are photos going
around they are fake mug shots and now
there are other photos going around that
people are claiming are real